You shut her down. Now, this look
communicates, oh, what is going on here?
This guy is crazy. Most of the time I
smell like a foot. I can barely get
myself out of my robe. You knew I liked
you. You've been on the show. Yeah. That
pause right there. That is letting
awkwardness sit with the power of AI and
hindsight. We are going to dive into
some of the most awkward celebrity
interviews and fix them. And hopefully
if you watch this and take a few mental
notes, you will learn how to avoid these
awkward situations in your own life as
well. Let's dive in using the powers of
artificial intelligence and unawward
this interaction. This is a good one.
First of all, congrats on your little
bump. Congrats on your little bump. In
this scenario, you guys may have seen
this video. Basically, what happens is
Blake Lively is pregnant. She's
beginning to show. My understanding is
this was a public knowledge thing at
this point. The interviewer comments,
"Congrats on your little bump. congrats
on your pregnancy. To which Blake
replies, congrats on not being pregnant
or maybe you're fattered. The
implication is not totally clear, but it
is not kind. And she will go on for the
rest of this interview to ignore the
host or the interviewer most of the
time. She'll be making eye contact
mostly with her co-star in this
situation. We can fix it though. We can
make it not awkward because Blake is now
catching a lot of crap for this
interview. And I'm just going to show
you with the power of AI how we would do
that. First of all, congrats on your
little bump.
Thank you. Problem solved. The rest of
this interview doesn't have to go the
way that it went. This problem doesn't
come back to bite Blake lively years in
the future. It is generally the most
charismatic and prudent thing to do when
you receive a communication from someone
that feels like it might be an attack is
to project positive intent onto that.
And what I often tell people is take any
ambiguous communication, especially
early in an interaction, and assume that
it's positive. even if they were trying
to take a shot at you. When you read
positivity into what people say, it kind
of can just derail that whole negative
train they were going down and flip
things to the positive and now you're in
the place you want to be anyway. So
that's what you can do. Let's say that
you are insecure about this and you
don't want people pointing that out.
Speak to that insecurity. Own the
insecurity and make a bit of a light
joke. This will let somebody know,
please don't continue going down this
particular route. If you speak your
insecurity rather than allowing it to
come through passive aggressively,
that's going to be much more effective.
Let's assume that you're on the flip
side. You're in the interviewer's shoes
and we get to this moment here. Do you
guys love wearing those kind of clothes
that you Yeah. Yeah. And you know,
working in digital wants to talk about
the clothes, but I wonder if they would
ask the men about the clothes. I would.
So, at this moment, one of the things
that you can do when someone is being
passive aggressive towards you is invite
them to take that passive aggression and
make it active. And you do that with a
question that speaks directly to the
thing that they're not directly saying.
Wants to talk about the clothes, but I
wonder if they would ask the men about
the clothes. Would you prefer that I
didn't ask you questions about clothes?
You stop the hiding behind, "I wonder if
people would ask other people about
this." And you bring you and I into this
and ask them their preference. One of
two things is going to happen here.
They're going to say, "Yeah, you know, I
I would like that." Or they're going to
say, "No, no, no." and now they're sort
of backtracking and undoing the thing
that they said and will probably wind up
apologizing in some form to you or at
least stopping with the continued
passive aggression because you've
invited it to come out directly. So,
let's move on to another sort of
situation that could be read as a
passive aggressive dig that made a
moment of awkwardness. This one, another
famous one. First of all, you smell
good, which is surprising. There's your
little dig. Why is that? I don't know. I
just wouldn't think of a guy who would
have a nice scent on. I'm going to
really work hard to not take that as a
shot. You know what I mean? Like, so
Jonah is actually in this moment doing
an externalization of the internal
monologue that I just described, which
is I'm going to take this ambiguous
communication and interpret it
positively and he's just saying that
he's that's what he's doing out loud cuz
I think you would smell nice. No, but I
don't I don't have Let's dissect that.
No, no, no. Let's go backwards. Okay,
let's go back.
So, the nice thing here is that Jonas
sort of calls it out, but then he
releases it. He doesn't continue to
punish Jimmy over and over and over
again. This is not a very uncommon way
for men to interact or these comedians
to start conversations like this with
some sort of a joke that is not
necessarily the implication is not the
nicest to the guest. The way to handle
this most of the time is to agree and
exaggerate and just let it go. So, what
that would look like here is something
like this. First of all, you smell good,
which is surprising. Most of the time, I
smell like a foot. I can barely get
myself out of my robe. So, this is a
really important occasion for me. To
agree and exaggerate that moment would
let it go just as quickly, in fact, more
quickly than calling it out and inviting
an awkwardness. And here's a great
example of Robert Downey Jr. doing that
same tip on the same show just a few
years earlier. Who is the biggest diva
in the whole cast? Who do you think?
Robert. Oh, you think it's Robert?
Get that off the monitor.
I do think what was happening here is
that Jonah was always the butt of the
joke in any sort of group. He was like
made fun of for being the Hollywood fat
guy. Are you the fat guy in Hollywood
still or do you have any other questions
that are smart? He came back after years
and having done therapy and was working
on asserting boundaries so that that
habit of being made the butt of the joke
wasn't something that continued to
happen to him all of the time and I
think he was a bit sensitive to it here
which is why he handled it the way that
he did. This is a totally viable,
reasonable way to handle a situation
where you don't like the comment that
somebody made to you and it will put
them on notice that they probably
shouldn't do that to you in advance cuz
it's going to get awkward, which is
actually a key thing that I did not
understand about awkwardness. There's
lots of times in your life where you
want to allow awkwardness to exist
because it's actually for the other
person to feel it so that they don't
continue to treat you in the
uncomfortable way that they've been
treating you. Which actually takes us
very well into our next clip. This one
is legendary. Let's watch the Ellen
Dakota Johnson birthday fiasco. Happy
belated birthday. When was your
birthday? It was October 4th. October
4th. How was the party? I wasn't
invited. I just want to pause here.
We'll come back to this. The context of
jokes really matters. There are jokes
where the context is, "You're so
awesome." There's jokes where the
context is, "You're such a loser." The
context of this joke is you should be
guilty for not being nice to me, which
isn't a great joke context. I'll unpack
this later, but let's see how it plays
out. Actually, no, that's not the truth.
Ellen, you were invited last year. No,
last time I was on the show last year,
you gave me a bunch of about not
inviting you, but I didn't even know you
wanted to be invited. So, this what
Dakota is doing in this moment is
allowing awkwardness to enter the
interaction. She is not saving Ellen
from it. She's saying, "No, this is what
happened." and she's contradicting her
and she's letting it roll, which is
fine. If you don't want somebody to make
that sort of comment, you have to kind
of let the awkwardness sit so that they
learn from it. You knew I liked you.
You've been on the show. Yeah. That
pause right there, that is letting
awkwardness sit. You knew I liked you.
You've been on the show many times. And
And don't I show
like you? Yeah. But I did invite you and
you didn't come. There's a real
opportunity to relieve tension, take
some responsibility here by cracking a
joke that is something to the effect of
cue the AI. Actually, no, that's not the
truth. Ellen, you were invited. Now I
feel like an idiot for trying to make
you feel guilty. Shows me. Right. It
just is a kind of taking back that
responsibility in a fun and playful but
clear way that would have, I think, made
this entire uh segment not nearly as
frustrating for people to watch back
years later. We're going to move on.
This one asked the question, "What can
you do if someone else is just breaking
every social norm and it's making you
feel uncomfortable?" You might have seen
this one. I've covered a lot of fashion
weeks. This is the first time I've run
in to Jim Carrey. Wait, tell me. Is it
true you're wandering the streets? You
need a date to the party. What's up? No,
no, no. I'm I'm I'm doing just fine. Uh
I just uh you know, there's no meaning
to any of this. So I I wanted to find
the most meaningless thing that I could
come to. So, initially she's just not
liking the way he responded to this
question, but it plays out a little bit.
I I don't think this is the moment where
it goes sideways. Well, they say they're
celebrating icons inside. Celebrating
icons. Boy, that is just the absolute
lowest aiming. Okay, so this moment
right here where she looks at the
camera, this look communicates, oh
what is going on here? This guy is
crazy. In these sorts of moments, for
one reason or another, we have a set of
social expectations of how we're going
to behave in a restaurant or at work or
something else, and then for whatever
reason, somebody else does not obey
those expectations. We can get vicarious
cringe in those situations. What you
want to learn to do is to sit back and
allow that awkwardness to exist without
feeling that it is your job to fix it.
And even these moments where somebody's
being absurd as long as they're not
hurting anyone can actually be enjoyable
and fun to watch if you don't take on
this burden of I have to make this
social arrangement work in the way that
I'm used to. In her case, it's I have to
talk about fashion and why it's
important in this particular interview.
Just sit back and let a guy who is one
of the most famous comedians in the
world just talk Icons, what do you
do? Do you believe in icons? I don't
believe in personalities. I don't
believe that you exist. But there is a a
wonderful fragrance in the air. This is
a wonderful opportunity for what we
talked about earlier, which is agree and
exaggerate. So he just said something to
the effect of, "I don't believe you
exist, but there's a wonderful fragrance
in the air." How could you agree and
exaggerate on that and start to play
with this energy rather than fight it,
which is what the interviewer continues
to do. I don't believe that you exist,
but there is a a wonderful fragrance in
the air. You're right, Jim. You don't
exist. We're all just monkeys wearing
rags wandering the world. Sounded
furious, signifying nothing. What does
it mean? you know, just just nonsense.
Cuz the problem was I was sitting here
trying to think of like a clever way to
respond. And if you watch the rest of
this, which is yeah, he's he's while
he's alluding to some philosophical and
spiritual ideas of uh no self, he's also
just making noise. You shut her down.
Now, the underlying thing here for
awkwardness is that we often take so
seriously what we're doing. And it's
easy for us sitting on the outside to
look at this woman at a fashion show and
say, "Yeah, obviously this doesn't
matter. Just enjoy the conversation."
But it's very hard to see those
opportunities in our own life to just
take it a bit easier and not allow the
awkwardness to exist because it's not
supposed to go any differently than it
is. These are what I have for you today.
If you've enjoyed this style of video,
let me know in the comments. I can do
more of them. I'm going to be trying
different kinds of uh formats and
talking heads and breakdowns and all
kind of stuff. So, let me know what you
thought in the comments. If you want to
work on your own awkwardness and turn it
into confidence and charisma, you might
want to check out our course, Charisma
University. It's our step-by-step
program that is designed to help you
master the skills of confidence and
charisma in just a few minutes a day so
that you stop feeling awkward and start
feeling powerfully in control socially.
Thousands of people have used Charisma
University to transform their social
lives, overcome any awkwardness they
have, advance their careers, and build
stronger relationships, including in
dating. And you can, too. The best part
is that Charisma University is
completely risk-f free. It comes with a
60-day money back guarantee. And if
you're not happy with the course for any
reason, you can get a full refund right
from inside the program, no questions
asked. So if you're ready to take your
confidence and your charisma to the next
level, click the link on the screen now
to get started. Either way, hope you
enjoyed this video and I will see you in
the next one.